shocking act
of unprovoked violence
right here in greenford
i understand that our community will
quite rightly be shot
and appalled
by this incident
as i am
too we are now able to aim to name the
man who has tragically lost his life
as mr thomas o'halloran
who lived in greenford
and was a very well known
a much loved member of our community
my thoughts very much remain
with mr o'halleran's family
and friends today
i'd also like to appeal
for their privacy to be respected
while they come to terms with their loss
detectives from the mets specialist
crime command
with the assistance of my officers
have been working tirelessly over the
last 20 hours
to understand what has happened
and to identify who is responsible for
this horrific crime
they have been following up a number of
inquiries
including the reviewing of cctv
and forensic examination of the area
however
we do need your help
we are appealing to anybody
with a dash cam or cycle helmet footage
that might have captured this incident
to get into contact with us
we believe that mr o'halloran was
stabbed
in western avenue
shortly after 4 pm
yesterday tuesday the 16th of august
before managing to travel 75 yards or so
on his mobility scooter
to runnymede gardens
where he flagged down
a member of public for help
so please
if you saw anything
we do need to hear from you
as of now
the public will see extra officers
patrolling the area over the coming days
they are there to protect you
and to help you
if you have any concerns
or information that you want to share
please approach those officers
i realize the dreadful impact
that incidents like this have on our
communities
i would like to reassure you all
that we are doing all we can to solve
the horrendous crimes
that we have seen across london
over the last few days
i stress
that london remains one of the very
safest cities in the world
as ever however
we do need your help
and so please come forward
with any information that you have
about this awful incident
or any other violent crimes
i would like to finish by saying
our thoughts and prayers
remain with thomas o'halloran
and his family
thank you all very much
thank you thank you very much
seven-year-old man
so that is chief superintendent sean
wilson there who is speaking following
that death of the elderly man who was
stabbed his name is thomas o'halloran um
the police there she heard sean wilson
superintendent there um said that he
lived in greenford um so he has now been
named he said he was a known member of
the community and his family of course
have now been informed he appealed to
the public to give the family some
privacy and some space while they come
to terms with the loss he says that
investigations are ongoing they're
currently following up a line of
inquiries including looking at cctv
footage and also looking at searching
the area and they're appealing for
anybody with dash cam footage or cc tv
to come forward well let's get more on
this now when i'll join from the scene
um here's sky's either bennett and
either just tell us more about um the
man that we've just learned about
yeah thomas halloran uh was thomas
o'halloran sorry was described there as
a grandfather 87 years old he lives in
greenfield and
and uh
superint
chief superintendent there sean wilson
said he was very well known in this area
and a much loved member of the community
it's understood he
played the accordion busked outside the
local supermarket
raising raising money and
the police officer there said that he
was stabbed actually not in this street
a bit further away 75 yards away he said
before making his way in his mobility
scooter
to where that blue crime scene tent has
been pitched and that is where he was
pronounced dead here yesterday afternoon
the attack happened in broad daylight
here between three and four o'clock uh
yesterday afternoon just before four
o'clock uh
he said there and um
right next to this very busy road this
is the a40 going into central london
it's always busy there would have been
traffic passing when this happened and
that is why the police officer there is
appealing to anyone who saw anything or
had dashcam footage or cycle helmet
footage to come forward and contact and
contact them in what is a very active
investigation we've seen several police
officers still here inside this police
cordon as well as forensic experts
working their way around the crime scene
as their investigation gets underway to
to identify who was responsible for what
was described just there as this
horrific attack